For this project, I will be using some vintage teacups, candle wicks,...
...and to not waste any candles, I will be reusing some wax remnants...
...that I have from previous candles.
First step is to heat and melt the wax.
Next, with a hot glue gun, glue the base of your wick to the bottom of your cup.
To hold the wick up straight, I recommend for you to use a ruler or a stick...
...to hold your wick up straight while pouring in the hot wax.
If you will be pouring on more than one layer of wax,...
...then I recommend for you to let your wax set for 30 minutes or so...
...before pouring on the next layer of wax to give yourself more variety in scent.
And there you have it.
A short, simple, and sweet DIY.